- It is Super Bowl this
weekend, (bleep) yeah, America!
(cheering)
The superest bowl, the
athletes competing on this,
the grandest of stages have worked
their entire lives for a chance to compete
at the highest level known to the sport.
That being said, which
of the following tweets
about Peyton Manning's forehead
received the most re-tweets?
(laughs)
A, Peyton Manning's forehead longer
than Taylor Swift's relationships.
(laughs)
- Ah, yes.
- If we talk about it too much,
does it become self-aware?
- [Man] It really does.
- Peyton Manning's forehead
is bigger than my entire face.
C, fun fact, in the
off-season, Peyton Manning
rents out his forehead as screen three
at the drive-in movie theater.
(ding)
- [Host] Yes.
- You know, I wanna say
C, but I think it's A.
- [Host] The Taylor Swift one, well...
- Only because, I feel like
Peyton Manning's forehead,
wasn't he in Megamind, that's my question.
(laughs)
- I actually think his
neck is getting so long
he's turning into the
Broncos' logo, he is like...
(laughs)
- [Host] That's what he's
ultimately morphing into.
- He's just a horse selling Papa John's.
(laughs)
- I don't, I've got a big forehead myself
and the attacks on Peyton,
I'm a quarterback also.
Yeah, I could throw a football 75 yards.
- [Host] Good to know, good to know.
- Does anybody here have a moist nerf?
(laughs)
- I actually thought "Does
anyone have a moist nerf"
would have been a great Taylor Swift song.
(laughs)
- Okay, by the way, we have
to get to the correct answer
which in fact is A, Taylor
Swift's relationships.
(laughs, applause)